Унітаз  - "привіт із СРСР".
Рукомийник - теж із минулого століття.
Вентиляція застаріла і працює не так добре, як хотілося б пасажирам.
Вони сидять біля вікон, заклеєних будівельною піною,
аби взимку не дуло. Сплять на полицях, які всі в латках.
А поручні безпеки приварені так,
що розкладати матраци чи залазити на полиці
без навичок скелелазіння - дзуськи!
Це плацкартний вагон "Укрзалізниці", який
обслуговує пасажирів уже четверте десятиліття.
Вагонів, які експлуатуються понад 20 років, в компанії  більше тисячі.
Усі вони, за даними "Укрзалізниці", на 92% зношені.
- Ми - як бригада реаніматологів. Ми кожен рейс
не даємо цим вагонам померти,
а хочеться працювати з задоволенням для себе і пасажирів.
Цей провідник уже після зйомки попросив
не показувати його обличчя і не називати номер потяга,
бо не хоче мати неприємностей у вигляді догани чи навіть звільнення.
Відкрито говорити натомість не боїться
менеджер "Укрзалізниці" Олександр Рудоманов.
У минулому блогер та громадський активіст,
він упродовж п'яти років після Євромайдану
висвітлював порушення на залізниці
й вимагав від чиновників їхнього усунення.
Рік тому Олександра запросили в "Укрзалізницю"
робити, в принципі, те ж саме, але в якості менеджера,
який майже щотижня їздить різними потягами,
знаходить і фіксує проблеми, а також
вносить пропозиції щодо їхнього вирішення.
У фокусі його уваги - не лише некомфортні умови
в потягах і на вокзалах, пасажири-"зайці"
і провідники, які займаються незаконними справами.
Рудоманов бореться за впровадження логічних речей,
як-то, наприклад, щоб пасажирам надали
зрозумілий алгоритм пошуку номерів вагонів:
не за принципом "голова-хвіст", а за вказівниками "Схід-Захід"
або "Північ - Південь".
Бореться він, зокрема, і за права  іноземних пасажирів,
які хочуть чути оголошення англійською не лише на вокзалі в Києві,
а й на маленьких станціях на кордоні з ЄС.
Проте такі ідеї, каже Олександр Рудоманов,
майже завжди наштовхуються на якісь нормативні акти,
інструкції чи закони, які подібних змін не передбачають.
Ба більше: в "Укрзалізниці", де звикли працювати,
як у радянські часи, ніби якась напіввійськова організація,
зафіксувати порушення, не кажучи вже про усунення, непросто.
- Коли я кудись виїжджаю, кожний начальник потяга,
станційний робітник, керівник знає, де я в цей момент знаходжусь.
У мене була ситуація: я приїжджаю на станцію,
а там вимита підлога. Думаю, ну, не може такого бути.
Приїжджаю на іншу станцію, заходжу в безкоштовний туалет.
У безкоштовному туалеті рушнички висять для рук,
усе вимито і такий рулон туалетного паперу стоїть. Ну... серйозно?
Деякі залізничники сприймають його як ворога,
деякі діляться своїми думками. Інколи
робітники залізниці не шкодують різких слів.
Хоча атмосфера не з приємних, Олександру Рудоманову
за рік таки дещо вдалося.
Втілення його пропозицій пасажири бачать щодня.
Так, у сидячих вагонах прибрали килимки з підлоги,
аби люди не дихали пилом. Вокзали зобов’язали
надавати пасажирам можливість заряджати
електронні пристрої, адже доступних розеток тут ніколи не було.
Курцям надали можливість палити у відведених для цього місцях.
У потягах провідників зобов’язали попереджати
про кондиціонери, які на окремих ділянках маршруту
можуть не працювати черех технічні проблеми.
У перспективі, пропонує Рудоманов, провідники
мали б оголошувати в вагонах про час затримки потяга.
Просувати ідеї в "Укрзалізниці", будучи її співробітником,
значно важче та довше, ніж у якості громадського активіста, зізнається Рудоманов.
- Тоді було навіть трохи легше,
тому що написав постик на Фейсбуці: "Зрада! Ганьба! Що це таке?!"
Підключив депутатів, зробили депутатські звернення.
5 штук звернень, всі такі: о Боже, це депутатські звернення, треба щось робити.
Тут ти пробуєш це зсередини. Умовно кажучи, мені, як і тоді,
можуть дати відписку, що мене здивувало.
Мовляв, немає технічної можливості.
І от так "степ бай степ", папірець на папірець.
Коли я сюди йшов, я думав: "Еге-гей! Шашку!"
Все зроблю швидко. Виявилося, що ні.
І все ж, вказує Рудоманов, за останні п'ять років
на залізниці відбулося багато змін.
Колись компанія мала щорічні збитки на рівні
кількох сотень мільйонів доларів.
Починаючи з 2015-го, підприємство перестало бути збитковим.
Прибуток за 2019 рік тепер уже колишній керівник компанії
Євген Кравцов навіть назвав рекордним: майже три мільярди гривень.
"Укрзалізниця" почала закуповувати нові вагони
на кшталт оцього - з кавоматом, сучасним туалетом,
зручними меблями в купе. Наразі, щоправда,
таких вагонів - одиниці,
проте керівництво компанії й уряд обіцяють
зайнятися оновленням потягів. Принаймні, є план
щодо смарт-ремонту застарілих плацкартів.
Якщо ж держава виконає своє зобов’язання
виділяти відповідні кошти, то "Укрзалізниця" може
щороку ремонтувати майже сотню вагонів.
- Останні роки "Укрзалізниця" демонструє гарний результат фінансовий.
Треба це конвертувати в якість надання послуг.
Будемо розробляти
в швидкому темпі
ті необхідні зміни для того, щоб дійсно громадянам
було відчутно, що дійсно щось змінюється.
Поки багато пасажирів позитивних змін не відчувають,
особливо коли стикаються під час подорожі з тарганами...
- Купа тарганів маленьких.
...чи брудною білизною.
- Мокра, брудна, в пасті.
Мало що відчувають і провідники, які їздять
у застарілих вагонах, інколи ремонтують їх власним коштом
та навіть самі шиють собі форму, аби виглядати добре.
- На жаль, форменим одягом поки нас керівництво не забезпечує.
Це ми купляємо за власні кошти.
Колишній громадський активіст Олександр Рудоманов
знає, як багато ще треба змінити на залізниці.
Водночас він упевнений, що реформувати "Укрзалізницю"
й перетворити її на цілком успішну компанію
з якісним сервісом - реально.
Для цього необхідне бажання як самої "Укрзалізниці",
так і уряду й парламенту, які повинні позбавитися
низки застарілих законів.
- Усе в цьому житті реально.
Було б бажання, був би консенсус.
Поки є в мене такий маленький вогник, що давайте
щось поміняємо, давайте щось робити.
Поки він є,  я буду працювати.
Якщо я буду відчувати, що стою понурим
і буду розуміти, що 90% технічно неможливо реалізувати, то я звільнюся.
У своїй щоденній боротьбі Рудоманов
дуже розраховує на допомогу звичайних пасажирів,
без яких реформа найбільшого державного підприємства
в принципі неможлива. Він нагадує про гарячу лінію,
на яку можна дзвонити цілодобово. Мовляв,
повідомлені через неї порушення доволі швидко усувають.
У тому, що саме активні та ініціативні люди
є запорукою успішної реформи "Укрзалізниці",
впевнені і в профспілках залізничників.
Причому шукати їх не обов’язково за межами України.
Ті ж провідники не лише знають
проблеми підприємства зсередини, а й нерідко
мають відповідну освіту та готові самі ініціювати
й запроваджувати необхідні зміни. В успішності
свого працедавця українські залізничники
зацікавлені не менше, ніж пасажири.